Telekom Internet ist abgekackt, ganz toll, ganz grandios, Telekom lull, ah mein Overwatch Account hat sich ausgelockt, auch gut, Blizzard Account nochmal aus, so, ich hoffe Streben geht wieder, Telekom lull, sollte eigentlich wieder alles funktionieren, schreibt mal bitte in den Chat, ob es wieder geht, ich gucke gerade mal, ich muss gerade mal bei mir selbst gucken, ja, ne, ja, sieht so aus, als geht es wieder, sehr schön,
Telekom lull, tja, kann man leider nichts machen, wenn die Telekom sagt, du spielst jetzt kein Overwatch, dann, so, F5, go, go, go, ihr solltet eigentlich kein Blackscreen mehr haben, ihr solltet jetzt Overwatch sehen wieder, ah, fuck, ich wollte instinktiv irgendwie da drauf klicken gerade, so, weiter geht's, angeblich habe ich auch null Viewer und alles im Arsch,
Alter, 2CP, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Why?
Why so viel 2CP?
Warum?
Mal gucken, was die Jungs hier picken, glaubst du, es lohnt sich, eine Switch zu kaufen, oder sollte ich eher bis Anfang 2018 warten?
Warum willst du warten, wenn es dafür jetzt Games gibt?
Ich weiß, dass Oasis nicht 2CP ist, Oasis ist 1CP, ja, aufpickt was, Leute, pickt irgendwas,
oh, ich habe ja gar keine Skins hier,
keine Skins, RIP, da geht nichts rein, ohne Skins, da kann einfach nichts reingehen,
ich muss mir jetzt mal den neuen Held angucken, was hat denn die für Fähigkeiten?
Heal, Heal, äh, Damage, Shift, okay, Shift ist so ein Evade, und E, oh nein, hey, das ist ja mal ein komplexer Support-Char, was ist mit Blizzard los,
Alter, was geht denn da?
Komplexer Support-Char, ich glaub's nicht.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Komplexer Support-Char?
Nö, nö, nö, warte,ahn.
Nenn dich weg!
Kann man sich selbst heilen?
Fuck, wie heilt man sich selbst, Beaura?
Mit dem Heilball, hä?
Ich muss den Heil erstmal ausprobieren.
Erste Mauer, dass ich den spiel jetzt.
Null, null, kann man sich?
Ich glaube, ich vermute mal, man kann sich selbst heilen.
selbst heilen, wenn man die Heilkugel
gegen sich schießt.
Hoffe ich mal.
Ach, Rechtsklick ist Live-Stil.
Ah, sehr interessant.
Meine Jungs machen das.
Easy, easy live.
Get carried, ich muss nichts machen.
Wisst ihr, wie sich das anhört?
Wisst ihr, wie ich das anhöre?
Das hört sich an wie ein Wasserkocher.
Passt mal auf.
Wie der hier reingerannt ist.
Was?
Was ist das? Alter, da kann sich überhaupt
einer zielen.
Da kann sich überhaupt einer zielen.
Okay, das ist kein Symmetra-Style.
Kein Symmetra-Style-Ding.
Das ist irgendwie...
Oh ne, das war Damage. Ich muss Heal machen.
Oh!
Jetzt reicht's mal. Bashen, Alter.
Wobei, wir gucken uns die Ulf
doch mal an.
Du brauchst nicht...
Ach, du brauchst nicht zielen. Ist das wie...
Ah, das ist wie ein...
Das ist doch so
so ein Symmetra-Style.
Okay, ich muss erst mal...
E ist das, das ist Heal-Kugel. Okay.
Auf, Gengu, komm her.
Oh, was hat das für ne Range?
Alter, was hat das für ne Range?
Alter, was...
Was hat das für ne Range?
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Heal, heal, heal, heal.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich hier so genau mache, ehrlich gesagt.
Jetzt schreckt.
So, das ist doch...
So spielt man zwar eigentlich keinen Supporter,
ich hör mich zu, aber warum nicht?
Was?
Oh!
Okay, naja.
Weil man sich da dran gewöhnt geht, das doch.
Warum haben wir den Punkt eigentlich
gerade eingenommen?
Ist so halb Symmetra.
Du musst mehr zielen, okay?
Okay, die...
Fliegt doch nicht weg!
Okay, da musst du dich erst mal dran gewöhnen.
Aber das geht schon.
Warum hast du dir einen neuen Account gemacht?
Weil ich keinen Bock hab,
mit meinem Main-Account
quasi indirekt die Games zu throwen,
bis ich auf nem angemessenen Skill-Level bin.
Aber mein Main-Account ist ja immer noch,
obwohl ich aufgehört hab zu spielen Ende Season 4,
ist er immer noch Highmaster, Low-Grandmaster,
Eingeranked, so intern,
in diesem internen Blizzard-Matchmaking-Rating.
Also nicht das, was angezeigt wird,
sondern das, was quasi an den Account gebunden ist.
Und da müsste ich jetzt erstmal wahrscheinlich
30 Matches verlieren,
weil ich halt sacke
und das Game nicht mehr kann,
bis ich dann wieder runter bin,
so auf Lowmaster, Diamond oder sonst was.
Easy.
Jetzt wird Sven's geschreckt.
Okay, Achtung, Achtung,
dass ich hier runtergeworfen werde.
Hab ich auch über mir grad was fliegen sehen?
Haha!
So, ja.
Welche Season ist das gerade?
Das müsste Season 6 oder so sein.
Schöne Fahrer.
Schneiber!
Boah, fuck.
Hast du den Reinhardt-Film geschaut?
Ja.
Fand ich geil.
Reinhardt-Film war echt super gemacht.
Will der Reaper sich denn mal heilen oder so?
So Antwerp.
Erstmal wieder reinkommen in das Game.
Johnny Diva?
Ich weiß nicht, was der da macht.
Smurfst du?
Ja.
Naja, ich würd's nicht smurfen nennen.
Ich mach mir den Account meinem Skill-Level angemessen.
Ich sacke halt in dem Game aktuell noch.
Muss mich erstmal wieder reinfinden.
Was?
Das hat nicht getroffen.
Rekt.
Wo kommt die Fahrer her?
Eins, zwei, drei.
Bam.
Der kommt da jetzt lang.
Was machen die?
Was ist das?
Easy Clap.
Warum bist du damals aus deinem Team raus?
Äh, mein Team...
Ich bin nicht aus meinem Team raus.
Äh, das ist, äh...
Längere Geschichte.
Ich weiß das gar nicht mehr so genau, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich bin nicht aus meinem Team raus.
Das hat irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz funktioniert.
Das hat sich auch mehr oder weniger dann aufgelöst, so.
Das ist doch doof gewesen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich total doof gewesen.
Das hat doch gar nicht übelst Bock gemacht.
Mein Legendär, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Mein Hanzo zeigt euch nicht.
Das sind mir mal keine unentschädigenden Sachen.
Ihr zeigt deinem Hanzo, wie sich das anhört.
Hanzo.
Ich zeige euch gleich meinen Legendär.
Winston.
Das ist nämlich richtig gut, ihr auf der Map.
Wo ist er hin?
Ich dachte, er hat sich geheilt, wenigstens.
Ich höre einen Roadhog.
Was haben die denn überhaupt?
Einen Fahrer?
Okay, da muss ich aufpassen, dass mich keiner runterwirft.
Es ist schon einer.
Reaper? Reaper?
Wo ist er?
Ich höre links was neben mir.
Ich muss mal runter.
Ein Soldier am Start.
Alter, verpiss dich.
Fakt.
Ich höre hinter mir was.
Hinter mir.
Ich muss weg.
Oh, kommt ein Roadhog.
Irgendwo links kam ein Roadhog.
Oh, knapp.
Komm her.
Exort.
Welche Heroes sind aktuell im Meta?
Winston?
Winston, D.Va, Genji, Tracer.
Oh.
Wo ist der Roadhog?
Sag mal.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Willst du mich nicht hucken?
Da.
Haben wir das jetzt?
Können wir das jetzt mal kriegen, ja?
Ist das möglich?
Oh!
Wenn du...
Ich sage, ich sage, das ist ein Level 2 Game.
Die sind halt...
Die haben das alle...
Im Vergleich zu mir haben die es halt alle noch nicht gespielt.
Aber ich bin schlecht.
Glaubt es mir.
Ich kann das einschätzen mittlerweile.
Halt gegen die Leute nicht.
Aber gegen Ultra-Noobs sieht man immer gut aus.
Weg.
Wuhu!
Habe ich doch gehört von der Seite.
I've got you in my sights.
Easy clapped.
Ähm.
Play of the game.
Ohohohoho.
Noohoho.
Mal gucken.
Habe ich...
Habe ich Q gedrückt.
Wie, das, das gibt Play of the Game?
Was habe ich denn da gemacht?
I've got you in my sights.
Ich habe wohl vor der Fahrer geholtert, anstatt es raufzuschieben.
Da ist oben das natürlich.
Play of the game.
Haha.
Easy Play of the Game.
Easy.
Die Fahrer steht auf Boots on the Ground.
Haha.
Die sollte besser mal Tour 2 spielen.
Äh.
Was hatte ich eigentlich?
Accuracy.
Ähm.
Hallo?
Ey, ich will nicht mein Secondary Fire sehen.
Aber 67...
67...
Ähm.
67% Helix Rockets treffen, ist nicht übel.
So, defend.
Komm.
Der Torb.
Der Torb geht ab.
Okay, ich warte erstmal, was die anderen picken.
Symmetra?
Mercy?
Oh.
Der Torb is real.
Wobei, ich brauche...
Der Torb hat doch auch ungefähr Self...
Hat doch auch sowas wie Self-Heal.
Warum neuer Account?
Weil mein Main-Account seit Season 4 im internen Blizzard-Matchmaking-Rating nicht wirklich
gefallen ist.
Und ich sacke in dem Game einfach mittlerweile.
Also, sacken ist vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber ich bin nicht mal wirklich drinnen in
dem Game.
Ich habe keinen Bock quasi indirekt Games zuzutrauen für Leute, die halt wirklich auf
diesem Rating sind.
Bis Blizzard dann...
Bis Blizzard Matchmaking erkannt hat, dass ich eben auf den Niedrigeren reingehöre.
Deswegen mache ich mir einen neuen Account.
Außerdem hat's...
Overwatch hat halt keine Möglichkeiten zum Üben.
Es gibt in Overwatch halt...
Okay, doch, jetzt vielleicht mit Team Deathmatch gibt's die Möglichkeit zu üben, ja.
Aber es gibt in Overwatch keine...
Quickplay ist halt shitfest.
Das ist ja noch ne halbwegs...
Nee, das ist für Quickplay noch ne gute Comp, was wir hier haben, ja.
Ähm...
Ja.
Es gibt eigentlich keine Möglichkeit zu üben, außer halt Private Lobbys zu machen, mit
Leuten, die's ernst nehmen.
Deswegen ist ganz gut, kann ich mich wieder halbwegs einspielen.
Oh, ich hab vorbeigeschossen.
Wow!
Der kann ja moven.
Oh, der kann ja moven.
Was soll das?
An was bin ich denn eben?
Er ist doch gestorben.
Hallo?
Noch nicht mal der Torb konnt's retten, hier.
Ich mal der Torb konnt's retten.
Ey, mein Turret.
Go, go.
Torb.
Move dich.
Beweg dich.
Nicht alle sterben, Leute.
Ist hinter mir irgendwas?
Leute, vor, vor, vor, vor.
Gleich gibt's Molten Core.
Gleich ist Molten Core angesagt.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
So.
Warum treffen die meinen Torb nicht?
Die treffen ja alle nix.
Ich bin ja der typische Quickplay-Torb gerade.
Der typische Quickplay-Torb.
Oh, oh.
Was?
Nein.
Ah.
Oh.
wir haben teleporter
was ist hier los
komm komm lade
top
alter
was ist hier los
hier reaper
nehm
die rüstung ist keksexplosiv
richtig
ich find das geil wie überfordert man von nem game sein kann
wenn man das ne weile nicht mehr gespielt hat
aber wie haben mich da
raus geultet hat
das war nice
ne ne das turret hat nicht max level 2
das turret hat max level 3
allerdings braucht man dazu
nen level 2 turret
und muss ein ulti drücken
komm die machen jetzt noch einen push
easy
naja
ich muss mich jetzt nicht so feiern
wenn das tatsächlich level 2 erbäsche
äh
c9 ja
richtig zihnei
bähhm
ich hab hunger
so
macht ihr so geräusche
ah das ist dieses dieses äh
s-team
ähm
sapfischer kannst du machen ja
ja ja lass uns lass uns ne runde zusammen spielen
gib mir xp
immer schön für sich selbst
na klar was
was denn sonst
huge plays
Lootbox, ganz wichtig, um so das bisschen Battlefront-Feeling aufkommen zu lassen.
Passend, der Torpspray, den brauche ich.
Ja, Sam Fischer, dann gib mir mal dein Battle-Dings da, Account.
Oh, ein Riot-Skin, jawoll.
Schick mir mal deinen Battle-Tag.
BetterTwitchTV spackt übelst rum auf der neuen Seite, ich kann den Chat auf der Seite
gar nicht mehr aufmachen.
Searcht noch.
Ja, DevilCube bis 25 dauert schon ein bisschen.
Ich bin jetzt auf meinem Hauptrechner übrigens umgestiegen von BetterTwitchTV auf FrankYourFacesZ
plus BetterTwitchTV.
Die Emoji-Add-on funktioniert mehr als mit BetterTwitchTV zurzeit und vor allem hat
es ein ordentliches Dark-Theme wieder.
Also, war eine Frage an euch, Twitch hat jetzt ja offiziell so einen Dark-Modus.
Wie findet ihr den?
Also, ich fand den alten von BetterTwitchTV besser, weil das ist jetzt so lila-dunkel
irgendwie.
Und das gefällt mir nicht.
Dieses Grau-Dunkel hat mir viel besser gefallen.
Jops, Sam Fisher, ich adde dich nach der Runde.
Die Runde spielen wir noch.
Ja, das Purple-Dark-Theme ist Crap, ja, finde ich auch.
So, was haben wir denn jetzt?
Hanzo?
Hanzo Re...
Der Klassiker?
Ich, ich, ich spiele alle Supports, na gut, Moira habe ich noch nicht gespielt, außer
ich spiele keine Mercy.
Aus Prinzip nicht.
Hasse.
Ich hasse Mercy.
Ich, ich weiß gar nicht, warum da so viele drauf abgehen.
Mercy ist so der, so der, der One-Trick-Held in Overwatch-Lechthänden.
Ui, Symmetra, ich heil dich, ich heil dich, Kollege.
Das war durch mein Speed.
Ich krieg mich da mal ein.
Oh Mann.
Das war durch mein Speed.
Ich bin von der Brücke gefallen.
Okay, auf jetzt hier.
Concentration.
Oh mein Scheiß.
Lasset euch heilen, Leute.
Auf geht's.
Okay.
Ich habe einen Teleporter gehört.
Oh, nee.
Gescattered.
Oh, ich bin ein Solo-Heal.
Solo-Heal als Loose-Hair ist jetzt nicht so toll.
Moment, kurz.
Ich sehe Chat nicht.
Bester Spot.
Auf, Leute.
Rein da.
Hanzo.
Was macht die hier?
Oh, oh, weg hier.
Was?
Der hat mich getroffen.
Fuck's nicht.
Nope.
Ich weiß, dass du zum Heal wolltest, Alter.
So nicht.
Lebt er noch?
Nein, nein.
Züber...
Was ist hier drinnen los?
Ich glaube, mit Support funktioniert das doch nicht so gut.
Nein, was machst du?
Alter.
Oh, nein.
Komm.
Warte!
Jetzt muss ich versuchen, meine Stärke reinzustecken.
So, ich bleibe jetzt hier stehen.
Ich bleibe jetzt hier stehen, bis ich regroupen werde.
Fertig.
Wow.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Rekt!
Nice.
Easy.
Easy Tire.
Komm jetzt, Leute.
Komm.
Go, go.
Achtung, die...
Aufschla...
Komm.
Kommt jetzt, Leute.
Kommt.
Was ist denn hier los drinnen?
Waaah.
weil es kommt auch keiner mit
aber kein Bock
so die Turrets
okay, ich spiele jetzt
irgendwas anderes
normalerweise kannst du King of the Hill
ohne Lucio gar nicht richtig spielen, aber
ich meine, das sind Level 5 Matches
ja
das könnte man mal spielen
also ich meine eigentlich
oh ne
Moira
Anna, komm ich spiele mal Anna
äh, was habe ich denn für ne
ah
ich greife mal ein bisschen was
du musst dich an das Level 3 Meter anpassen
ja
den Clip muss ich mir nachher
angucken, der Junkman war zu geil
wie er da runter geflogen ist
erstmal Vorsprinten
oh
die Granate fliegt so schon mal nicht mehr
mach den platt
eigentlich
Gengu bleib stehen
oh fuck
welche Maus ich genommen habe
ich habe eine Zoe EC2A
I require healing
Healing brauchen der Genji
wer hätte das gedacht
dass er Healing braucht
kennt man von Genjis gar nicht, dass sie Healing brauchen
ja Leute
ich sehe nichts
Das ist absolut random, ey.
Du fliegst da gar nicht durch.
Das ist vollkommen random.
Ich glaube, eigentlich kannst du nur Soldier spielen.
Das ist so absolut unkontrolliert, ey.
So, Kenji, aufgeh...
Oh, fuck.
Nein, ich wollte nicht.
Das ist echt...
Nee, Leute, das ist mir zu random.
Du kannst kein Support spielen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist einfach nur total verteilt und...
Nee.
Aber wir können nicht ohne Support spielen.
Das kann...
Auf, Soldier.
Mach ihn nochmal platt.
Ah, kein Bock drauf.
Oh, ist nicht schlimm.
Ist kein...
Ich...
Keine Ahnung, ey.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Support ist für Pussys, ja.
Das ist so total random, ey.
Links zwei, rechts zwei.
Unten einer, oben einer.
Kenji, please switch.
Ja, das liegt nur am Kenji.
Eindeutig.
Nur.
Was sonst?
Nur am Kenji.
Sonst nix.
So, easy.
So, jetzt adde ich mal hier den Sam Fisher.
Wo ist er denn?
So, adden.
Play of the game.
Hallo.
Oh, ich hab dir ne Einladung geschickt.
Ja, nee, Support kannst du eigentlich voll vergessen, ne?
Wenn...
Das braucht so'n...
So...
Ich mein...
What?
Ist das...
Ist das Boy oder Grill im Chat?
Ich bin erst Level 3.
Das dauert ja ewig.
Oh.
Ähm, Leon, ähm, ich bleib erst mal hier Duo-Queue, sonst wird's, äh, im Match, also,
sonst kriegt das, das wahrscheinlich gar nicht gebacken.
Weiß man schon, wann die neuen Intel-Boards rauskommen?
Was für neue Intel-Boards?
Du meinst die, äh, Z370 für, ähm, Mittelklasse?
One CP.
Äh, ähm.
Ähm.
Okay, was nehmen wir dann?
Was nehmen wir dann?
Zarya.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kriegen wir ein bisschen Speed.
Zarya schon lange nicht mehr gespielt.
Season, Season 2 hab ich die, glaub ich, gespielt.
Am meisten.
Von allen Helden.
Ich glaub, Season 2 war das, ähm, ähm, wo Zarya richtig gut war.
Zuerst hab ich schon mal geleafed, oder auch nicht?
Oh, kriege ich denn eigentlich Erfolge für Spawn?
Also sehe ich das richtig?
Ich habe gerade Erfolg gekriegt,
dafür, dass ich gespawnt bin.
Ach ne, das war der Erfolg für
wir sind im Team, im Game gejoined.
Ich habe irgendwas im Hals,
das ist ja schlimm.
Oh, wir sind in einem richtigen Game gelandet.
Jetzt sind die ja gar nicht mehr so voll,
bobs drinnen.
Ach ne, das liegt daran, weil ich mit seinem Fischer geqt bin.
Das wird so anstrengend.
Was ist hier los?
Wo sind die alle hin?
Sind die alle weg?
Es ist total...
Ich weiß, woran ich was machen soll.
Simple Geometry.
Oh oh.
Oh oh oh.
Das ist toll.
Oh, wir haben Speed.
Haben eigentlich so gut wie geworden schon.
Ja, schon so gut wie geworden.
Das Gefiede ist da Wahnsinn.
Was ist da los?
Hook mich.
Will, dass du mich hookst.
Haha.
Okay, man kann schon...
Oh, sind alle drin?
Sind alle drin?
Ah, wir haben eine Pulsbomb gekriegt.
Gut.
Wir haben einen Pulsbomb.
Ja, wir haben eine Pulsbomb.
Echte Gegner, PogChamp.
Ja, das sind wirklich echte Gegner.
Werf, Pa.
Werf.
Wo ist er?
Warum hat der Reaktion in der Chunks-Version?
Wo sind meine Leute?
Warum hat der Chunkrat so gute Reaktionen?
Hat er es nicht gezündet, als er Lucy das Schild hatte?
Was?
Was ist hier los?
Den Hanzo juckt der Punkt absolut nicht.
Dem ist das vollkommen egal.
Der heißt bestimmt Legolarharz oder so.
Nee, heißt er nicht.
Das sind immer die Besten, die so geile Namen haben.
Hanzo Main und Legolarharz.
Den holen wir uns.
Oder auch nicht.
Achtung, die kommen.
Kommen die denn jetzt lang?
Easy Clap.
Oh, nee.
Leute.
Was?
Wie hat er mich gekillt?
Ach, das war die...
Ach, nee.
Ich kack.
Das war die Diva-Bombe.
Max spielt wieder Overwatch.
Ja.
Wir verlieren das auch noch.
Und wisst ihr, warum wir verlieren?
Weil ich es verkackt habe.
Weil ich oben rechts hingegangen bin, anstatt einfach mal meine Leute in der Mitte zu babbeln.
Richtig dumm.
Richtig dumm gewesen, ey.
Oh.
Huge.
Da geht er ab, der Sam Fisher.
Was?
Nein.
Der Chosen ist da.
Das ist schon...
Ey, aber Leute, die ich hier als Overwatch-Kenner noch...
Oh, war das schlecht, ey.
Oh, war das schlecht.
Und ich muss mich hauen.
Ich muss mich dran gewöhnen.
Vor allem im aktuellen Meta.
Ich muss Mercy killen.
Das Wichtigste.
Ich mach das immer noch nicht mit genug Fokus.
Außerdem mach ich viel zu wenig Damage für Zarya.
Ich mein, keine Medaille.
Das ist eigentlich für eine Zarya nicht...
Normalerweise müsste als Zarya...
Moment, warum hat das jetzt kein Damage gebracht?
Ich check's hier nicht.
Wo sind denn hier die Gegner überhaupt?
Ach, da ist einer auf dem Punkt.
Sagt es halt einer.
Eine So...
Mercy.
Na, oh Mann.
Das ist doch schlecht wieder gewesen.
Das ist doch schlecht gewesen, ey.
Suche Team.
Biest.
Ah, ist das schlecht, Alter.
Ich muss...
Mercy...
Äh, nicht Mercy.
Zarya kommt eigentlich hauptsächlich drauf an.
Also, neben dem, dass man halt...
Dass man richtig steht.
Und so nicht.
Du hast doch...
Du hast doch einen Smurf draußen.
Oh, ihr braucht Schild.
Das ist ja ein Fischer.
Schild gebraucht.
Gengu, komm her.
Juhu.
Nein, noch nicht.
Ach.
hab's probiert ich habe es probiert wenn du mitmachst dann wäre ich viel zu hoch
eingerankt danach wieder weil du mich carries keine damage medaille mit sarja
das ist absolut lächerlich schlecht
hallo hallo wo seid ihr denn leute wo sind alle
so schlecht ich habe mich selbst gekillt
der genji hat mich überfordert das war zu viel gerade
auf leute kommt leute ihr müsst den own
huge
aber erst mal selbst in die luft gesprungen
hallo easy carry easy clap habe ich überhaupt easy clap aktiviert als
emot wenn nicht ist das ein fast nicht zu entschuldigen das versäumnis
das kann man hier einspiel und wir haben keinen support das kann man auch nicht spielen
ja
bleib mal solche
bei orisa ist hier ist gut University online
ja
was meine ethnische platz
es heißt ist nicht die sind pregnantes gibt's nicht
was macht ihr
Nein!
Overwatch ist...
Ein Overwatch ist nix, RIP, Leute.
Ich weiß nicht...
Ich hab nur ganz kurz im Chat gesehen, dass es einer geschrieben hat.
Die letzten paar Sachen haben ziemlich viele Zuschauer angezogen.
Oh, ich hab mich hochgearbeitet auf Silber.
Oh, wir haben's, wir haben's.
Leute, nicht den Punkt vergessen, nicht den Punkt vergessen.
Oh, ne, ich hab nur noch Browser.
Ja, und ihr wolltet mir nicht glauben, dass ich sacke, ey.
Ist doch offensichtlich.
Was?
Warum ist das Ding nicht gestorben gerade?
Jetzt aber.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich das Problem an Overwatch, dass das Rank-System suckt.
Aber Overwatch an sich...
Ich sag in den Chat, einzige Overwatch an sich.
Ist eines der geilsten Games der letzten Zeit.
Keine Frage.
Lootbox.
Kannst du den Chat nach oben links verschieben?
Ja, kann ich machen.
Äh, aber dann sieht man die FPS nicht mehr.
Was ist euch lieber?
Chat oben rechts?
Chat oben links?
Chat unten links?
Wir können Chat unten links machen.
Was?
Oder unten rechts?
Oder so.
Wie ist das?
Wo wollt ihr Chat?
Ich find da oben rechts Dirts eigentlich am wenigsten.
Aber...
Sucht's euch aus.
Oben links, Beste?
Gut, mach's oben links.
Kann ich auch machen.
Das ist kein Ding.
Ui.
Mach mal hier so, dass man noch FPS sieht, okay?
Ist das so gut?
Oh, in der Mitte, ja.
Ist klar.
Das stört's aber überhaupt nicht.
Das Problem an Overwatch ist tatsächlich, da gebe ich dir recht, dass das Rank-System suckt.
Das ist so.
Das Problem ist auch...
Ähm...
Ranked soll ja so, sagt der Blizzard zumindest, Ranked soll so die Nachwuchsförderung für Overwatch League sein.
Das Problem ist, dass quasi ordentliche Teams komplett anders spielen, als es im Ranked der Fall ist.
Was wiederum zu dem Problem führt, dass Overwatch League nicht wirklich...
Also diese ganze Competitive-Szene ist halt recht dünn in Overwatch.
Und Ranked ist definitiv kein Modus, wo man Nachwuchs...
Findet.
Ja, ein gut...
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Damals kippt bei, ähm...
Wie hießen sie damals?
Reunited?
Reunited hießen sie noch.
Den haben sie auch gescoutet, glaube ich, in der Beta übers Ranked.
Aber wenn du hier nicht gerade konstant Top 10 bist, ähm...
Was schwierig ist, sagen wir mal so, als Support-slash-Tank-Spieler, dann...
Äh, wirst du da auch nicht, äh...
Äh...
Äh, gefunden.
So, gucken, ob die Widows spielen oben links.
Gerne Widows.
Nope.
Bitte.
Keine Widows.
Entschuldigt mich da jetzt hin.
Die gehen alle immer so hart rein.
Was machen die da vorne eigentlich alle?
Was?
Fuck, ich dachte, er ist tot.
Hä?
Hätten wir jetzt mal eine Mercy gehabt.
Haha, der Chosen.
Genji One-Trick.
Du kannst doch viel mehr spielen als Genji mittlerweile.
Hast du nicht auch übelst gut Widow gespielt, Chosen?
Ich bilde mir das ein.
Du warst doch auf dem Weg zum Widow-Main.
Was machen die alle da vorne?
Moment, war hier nicht ein Heal...
War hier nicht ein Heal-Pack irgendwo?
War hier nicht irgendwo ein Heal-Pack?
Mann, macht da...
Macht hier doch mal einer platt.
Ich krieg die Krise, ey.
Macht hier doch mal einer...
Oh.
Auf jetzt, Leute.
Vor, vor, vor.
Komm.
Hallo, Damage machen.
Einer.
Please.
Come on, bro.
So, ich geh jetzt auch vor.
Die gammeln alle so gerne so weiter vorne rum.
Aim.
Wo ist der Bastion am Start?
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Was war das denn?
5k ist das höchste ja. 28%! Oh Gott! 28%! Next Taimou hier, 28%. Kommt Chosen, 28% kriegst du auch hin, oder? Mit deiner Widow.
Ich darf übrigens nicht so viel ins Brain verfallen. Eigentlich musst du so schießen. Hier ist Winston gut. Aber wir haben nur Winston. Winston, D.Va, Kombi, Winston, Zarya. Winston, D.Va, also Winston, Solo-Tank. Wobei, wir haben ja mit Orisa das Geld.
Genau, Chosen. 28% Critical Hit.
Also der Reinhardt-Charge war wirklich random gerade.
Hallo, mach ihn tot.
Oh Gott! Fuck! Kriegst du ein Reds? Haben wir ein Reds? Ah, wir haben keine Mercy. Okay, egal.
Was ist da eigentlich? Was ist da eigentlich hinten?
Nein! Leute, macht doch einen Damage auf diesen Kack, Reinhardt!
Warum macht da nicht einer einen Damage auf den Reinhardt? Einen! Einfach anhusten!
So, huge ult, huge ult.
So, scheiß drauf. Leck mich.
Eigentlich wollte ich die aufheben, ne? Fürs nächste Engagement, aber man weiß ja nie so genau.
Das stimmt, Jax, das ist richtig. Hätte ich mir Headshots getroffen, hätten wir es gewonnen.
Warum hat denn der schon wieder Beat?
Der hat Shatter, der guckt so.
My name!
So nicht.
Komm mal ein bisschen zurück.
Komm doch mal. Oh, Mann.
Oh, jetzt ist es hier.
Ja.
Easy, Klaas.
Na, immerhin. Immerhin auch gewonnen, ey.
Ich bin auch voll aufgeregt, ey. Ich kenne das, wenn man so aufgeregt ist.
Dann hast du immer so das Problem, so kleine Entfernungen.
Ordentlich, ne?
Also, wenn du von da nach da willst, dann zitterst du immer so ein bisschen dabei, wenn du aufgeregt bist.
Das klappt nicht.
Das geht nur, wenn du richtig entspannt bist.
Dann.
Also, entspannt und fokussiert.
Dann geht's ab.
Ups.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich geh mal...
Äh...
Du kannst...
Ah, fuck.
Egal, ich geh mal ganz kurz gucken, wegen Futter.
Arriving at watchpoint Gibraltar.
Prepare your defenses.
Select your hero.
Aber...
Ich weiß...
Dass meine Mechanics jetzt nicht die krassesten auf der Welt sind.
Deswegen will ich auch kein DPS mehr hin.
Sondern bleib bei Support und bisschen Off-Tank und Tank und sowas.
Ihr könnt den Cursor nicht sehen?
Ernsthaft?
Könnt ihr den Cursor nicht sehen?
Klar.
Ihr müsst doch den Cursor sehen.
Na?
So, was sind wir denn hier?
Defense.
Ich hab noch nie Orisa gespielt.
Noch nie.
Orisa.
Ähm...
Die neuen Roadhog hab ich auch noch nicht gespielt.
Easy.
Ähm...
Man cancelt jetzt mit Left, ne?
Ich war früher so ein...
So ein Diva-Per-Schuss-Canceler.
Aber das geht ja nicht mehr.
Ja, eher.
Es könnte schon sein.
Ah, du weißt, dein DPS ist eh nicht so meins.
F.
Soll ich unsere Widow jetzt...
Alter!
Move dich!
Ich hänge fest.
Wow!
Ah, fuck.
Ich dachte, er ist runtergefallen.
Was?
Ach, stimmt, Mann.
Das ist ja auch Raketen.
Ist ja neu.
Ganz vergessen.
Ey, ey, Raketen.
Ah!
Oh, nice!
Boah!
Ich glaub's nicht!
Wieso verkackt du...
Ich hab's sogar noch gesehen, wie er das geworfen hat.
Aber das passt schon.
Man hat sich erstmal wieder dran gewöhnt.
Stimmt, mit E-Raketen.
Die schießen aber, wie ich gesehen hab, nicht sofort.
Die brauchen erst ein bisschen.
Was gibt's denn da?
Der kommt jetzt hochgesprungen.
Nein, fuck.
Dachte ich.
Ah.
Hätte ich jetzt meine Raketen verwendet?
Ich kann...
Warum hab ich meine Raketen nicht benutzt?
Weil ich dran gedacht hab, dass das Scheiß den Raketen hat.
Ach, die Raketenkammer wäre eine Defense-Matrix.
Alter, gibt's doch nicht.
Ich kack du.
Ey, ich treff nichts.
Na ja, die wird auch gekillt.
Wobei, die wird auch gar nicht...
...auch ein bisschen besser.
Das siehst du an dem Greifhaken-Movement.
Haha, ja.
Ja, ja.
So sieht's aus.
Ich dachte eigentlich auch lieber nicht.
Ach, man muss sich ja gar nicht mehr verstecken.
Man muss sich ja gar nicht mehr verstecken.
Siehst du mal, wie lange ich den Kram nicht gespielt hab.
Äh, okay.
Man muss sich ja gar nicht mehr verstecken.
Okay, Raketen, Raketen.
Ist gut.
Mercy, Mercy.
Maximus Mercy on.
Perfekt.
Ach, Mercy.
Ach, man kann jetzt ja fliegen und schießen und gedulden gleichzeitig.
Ich check's noch null.
Ich muss mich echt dran gewöhnen, dass ich das alles gleichzeitig machen kann.
Wo sind eigentlich meine Leute?
Macht da irgendeiner mal Damage drauf jetzt?
Boah, hinter uns.
Scheiße.
Hahaha.
Die war auch...
Was macht der denn da?
Achtung, huge, huge, old, huge.
Huge.
Man.
Wo ist die verkackte Mörse?
Da kann's nix machen.
Aber da muss ich mich wirklich erstmal dran gewöhnen, dass man, dass man Raketen und, und, und schießen und, und gedulden...
Ah, ich, in meinem Kopf ist D.Va immer noch, sobald du anfängst zu schießen und was zu machen, äh, äh, äh, kannst du dich nicht mal richtig bewegen.
Da, no settings.
Seht ihr mal, wie lange ich den Kram nicht gespielt hab.
Wie lange gibt's die D.Va-Änderung schon?
Vier Monate?
Drei Monate?
Moin, Stargator.
Ich muss mir D.Va jetzt nochmal angucken.
Muss ich mich ein bisschen dran gewöhnen, weil das Ding ist übelst OP.
Das merk ich gleich.
Ein Wunder, dass das überall gespielt wird.
Außerdem brauch ich noch das richtige Mele-Timing.
Oder warten wir mal, was die anderen picken.
Na, Jax.
Wenn's ein gescheites Ranking ist...
Wenn's ein gescheites Ranking-System gäbe, das wär Overwatch das Spiel, was du rauf und runter spielen könntest, hunderte Stunden, aber nee, gibt's nicht.
Da spielt er wirklich Overwatch, ja.
Spielt er wirklich.
Nee, das Gaubs, das Ranking-System ist kacke.
Einfach, dass es keine Solo-Queue ist, dass es dieses komische Win-Loss, ähm, dieses, ähm, nicht Win-Loss basiert, sondern so dieses...
Spiel-basierte, wo sie denken, hey, sie könnten irgendwie bewerten, wie gut jemand gespielt hat.
Außerdem sind die Matches meistens nicht ausgeglichen.
Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr, äh, so.
Was geht mit dem ab?
Mit der Tracer.
Wenn die einen Chunk gehört haben, liegt davor jetzt ein...
Rekt.
So geht das.
Bam.
Doch, geht doch.
Easy.
A, Capture.
Commence Attack on Objective B.
I'm gonna shoot you down.
Sniper, don't get caught.
Overkill.
Hehehe.
Das hast du dir anders vorgestellt, Tracer, ne?
Schießen und...
Ach, man kann sogar schießen und Rockets gleichzeitig.
Du kriegst aber kein Move und Rockets gleichzeitig.
Okay, das ist cool.
Oh, pass mal auf.
Huge Ult, huge Ult.
Nee, aber nicht sterben, Leute.
Sniper, don't get caught.
Huge Ult.
Gefressen.
Noch mehr Ult.
Die Ult hätte ich nicht setzen sollen.
Die hätte ich aufheben müssen.
Die Ult hätte ich aufheben müssen.
Ich hab gedacht, wir kriegen das direkt.
Weil wir haben die alle gleichzeitig gekillt.
Oh, huge.
Ups.
Ha.
Ah, hätte ich mir die Ult mal aufgehoben.
Ich dachte mir, ich hau die direkt auf den Punkt.
Da kann keiner dran.
Das Problem ist, wir haben gerade alle auf einmal gekillt.
Was natürlich ziemlich ersackt ist.
Und dann hab ich quasi ins Leere geultet.
Jawoll.
Easy, easy win.
Aber die Aktion auf Punkt war nicht schlecht.
Müssen wir zugeben.
Wusin no kei wo kurere!
Gehen wir mal dem Genji was.
Weiter jetzt.
Oh, die hab ich auch noch nie gespielt.
Ich glaub, ein Quickplay-Match
haben wir als die Neubauer
da drauf mal gemacht.
Kann Zenyatta irgendwas Neues mittlerweile?
Naja.
Gucken wir mal, ob meine Ball-Skills noch am Start sind.
Als Support zu carryen, um jetzt mal auf den Chat, ich weiß nicht, wer es geschrieben hat, ich habe es ja eben nebenbei gesehen.
Als Support zu carryen ist ja auch nicht die Definition von Carry.
Carryen kannst du ja eigentlich bloß als CD bzw. DPS.
Der Support muss den Carries ermöglichen zu carryen.
Wenn natürlich deine Carries scheiße sind und nicht carryen, dann kannst du als Support auch nicht so viel machen.
Klar, du kannst richtig krasse Plays mit Ana machen, mit Zenyatta und so, das geht schon.
Aber das ist nichts gegen einen guten DPS Tracer oder sowas.
Ja, das macht ja auch ein Smurf, dann leveln wir zusammen bis 25.
Walls.
Rechts!
Die Widow!
Balls, wenn Balls werden da gethrowt.
Ach, du hast schon zwei, stimmt, stimmt.
Nein, nein, nein, Diablo 3 spiele ich nicht mehr.
Das hat gut reingehauen da oben, ich weiß nicht genau, was das jetzt gewesen ist.
Perfekt.
Ich muss mehr Balls werfen.
Ich ulti mal für unseren Reinhardt.
Leute, macht was!
Was saugt mich das da aus?
Sack.
Ah!
Pusherino, Pusherino!
Haha, lol.
C9, richtig, zweites.
Also, das kann man schon immer mehr C9 nennen.
Das war C11 oder so.
Oh, oh, weg hier, weg hier, weg hier.
Jetzt wüsste ich schon, was war.
Da habe ich jetzt absichtlich meinen Ulti nicht gezogen, weil ich meine, wir waren schon alle tot.
Wenn die Balls gethrowt...
Go, go!
Es tut mir leid, dass ich ausfühlen durfte.
Auf!
Los!
Geht ran!
Mach dir nur aus die Platten.
Und vergesst den...
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Easy.
Easy clap.
Ich müde mich mal kurz, ich muss in den Brötchen reinbeißen.
Basiert mit Hammers am Fischer, ja.
Ich hab's gesehen.
Oh ne.
2CP.
Größter Kackspielmodus, der je in einem Game erfunden wurde.
Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Der zweitgrößte Kackmodus, der je in einem Game erfunden wurde.
Mit ein paar Tweaks, könnte ja noch ganz gut sein.
Ja, aber nein.
2CP.
Sorry, Winston Action.
Diva, Winston, Winston, Diva, Samia.
Oh, Samia.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, was sie picken wollen.
Ich warte eigentlich immer drauf, ob wir wirklich auch einen supporten oder sowas.
Aber scheiße, aber er ist Quickplay.
Ist das immer noch Clickplay?
Ja klar, ich bin Level 6.
Quickplay.
Also, das ist bis Level 25 Quickplay.
Das braucht bestimmt 3 Streams.
Bin ich 25, bitte.
Ja, Jaws, da bin ich auch gespannt.
Die Koreaner, ich dachte ja, als ich die letzten Apex-Regeln gelesen hab, es wird kein 2CP gespielt, aber dann doch.
Wo stellt man sich hier übrigens am besten hin?
On Point, ne?
On Point dürft wahrscheinlich fast mit am besten sein.
Attack Speed.
Am Anfang mal ne Runde Spammery.
Ich spiele auf meinem Skill-Rang angemessen.
Also schlecht.
Schneiber! Schneiber!
Ah! Sombra!
Verpiss dich!
Heal please.
Äh, wo ist Heal nochmal? Da.
Ich seh nix.
Der Dicke ist vor mir.
Was machen die da vorne eigentlich?
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist gerade.
Was ist das?
Oh ne, hätt ich mal E gedrückt.
E-T-F.
Gibt's doch nicht.
Das ist so verteilt alles.
So verteilt und random.
Okay, das war jetzt ein wenig Overkill.
Sterben die da nicht?
Ach, das ist ein Sombra.
Okay.
Was machen die eigentlich so oft da vorne drinnen?
Ha, Lauf am Rutsch runter in der Hand.
Jetzt hat's ihn gepackt, den E-Ax.
Hinter, hinter, hinter, hinter, hinter.
Hinter, hinter!
Das ist halt das Problem, wenn du so vorne rumstehst.
Die Sombra hat sich da gleich wieder vorbei.
Ich bleib jetzt hinten, dass ich da dran kann.
Wollen wir das echt verlieren jetzt so?
Ich geh da nicht vor.
Einmal Sombra vorbeigelaufen, wobei die ist noch vorne.
Fuck.
Hoff, hoff, hoff, hoff, hoff, hoff, hoff, hoff.
Oh, macht sie doch!
Moment, wo ist meine Maus?
Meine Maus ist weg.
Das war mein Hanzo.
Oh, fuck.
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Das kann man doch nicht verlieren.
Lol, Alter.
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Wie kann man das verlieren?
Egal.
Ja.
Grav viel Ecks.
Ähm.
Sein Fischer kann genau ganz leicht nächstes Game suchen.
Ja.
Schon andere Player-Icons?
Reinhard.
Weißige Player-Icon.
Aber merkt sofort den Unterschied, ne?
Bei den Spielern.
Von meinen Level 5 Games zu den hier jetzt.
Ich mein, die sind jetzt ja auch nicht wirklich krass oder so.
Oh, ne.
2CP.
Schau mal da.
Wie viel 2CP haben wir denn noch?
Ja.
Bitte picken sie jetzt.
Das ist ein Problem für die Menschheit.
Komm, wir spielen mal Orisa.
Was kann, was kann das Viech überhaupt?
Schild?
Ah, das ist dieses, dieses Teil.
Was ist Shift?
Ach, da wo man nicht gehuckt werden kann.
Hm.
Probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Und nie Orisa gespielt.
Ah, das ist der, das ist das, was man nochmal auf, auflösen kann.
Pass mal auf die Crappen.
Jetzt.
Die, die, die crappen wir jetzt, die Sombra.
Hopp.
Oh Mann.
Eckt.
Ruff hier.
Ruff hier, Jungs.
Ruff.
Nicht so viel rumgammeln.
Das war Moira, ernsthaft?
Das war, ich kenn die Leute, ha, es hat nicht.
Ich stell das jetzt mal hier hin.
Weil die können es ja wieder nicht.
Nicht lassen, davor zu rennen.
Komm her, Mercy.
Master Fister.
Moment, was ist Shift?
Auf, Leute.
Wo ist hier was?
Wo ist denn hier was?
WTF?
Ich hab's null gecheckt, wo, wo, wo?
Wie sie rekt.
Nicht, nicht, dass es an mir lag.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was ich für ein Ult hab.
Oh.
Okay.
Also.
An die Orisa-Fähigkeiten muss ich mich noch gewöhnen.
Vor allem das richtige Timing.
Ich geh mal davon aus, wenn man es richtig gut macht,
weil die Schüsse von Orisa auch so langsam sind.
Ha, ha.
Ha.
Scatter voll die Eier.
Ähm.
Weil man.
So langsam schießt mit Orisa.
Wenn man das gut kann, kann man bestimmt schießen, während diese Kugel fliegt.
Und wenn man den dann ransaugt, den Gegner, dann saugt man den quasi dahin, wo die Schüsse auch hingehen.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Also sprich, dass du gleich so Instant Damage auf den machst.
Aber da brauchen wir schon ein gutes Timing für.
Also nicht so.
Nicht so wie so eben hier da, ne?
Ja, ist ja ein Fischer.
Huge Rass.
Huge.
Massive.
Ich guck zu viel Taimo.
Das steckt an.
Und seit ich Taimo gucke, respektiere ich auch Frauen.
Falls auch jemand Taimo guckt.
Das ist auch ein Schwätzer, ey.
So, was haben wir hier jetzt zu bieten?
Moment.
Haben wir den krassen Attacktor?
Ähm, ehrlich, das kann eigentlich nicht funktionieren.
Es sei denn,
Firefox checkt das irgendwie, aber das glaub ich dann.
Haha, der Looch, oh weh.
Ja, ja, ja, das stimmt.
Das ist der Beste.
Wo Taimo, wo Taimo den Campery-Text liest, ja.
8 Inches.
Aber die Looch, oder die Looch, ich weiß nicht, wie man das genau ausspricht,
bis zu der, ähm,
der Genji-Main?
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob du als letztes noch Genji-Main warst.
Was? Äh, äh, ja, ja, ja.
Der Name sagt mir nämlich doch irgendwas.
Was, was zum Taum...
Komm, Reinhard.
Der Name sagt mir irgendwas.
Irgendwie verbinde ich das mit Genji.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau, woran das liegt.
Kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Ach, das kann man nicht blocken, das Ding, ah.
Haha.
Hallo, Leute?
Okay.
Oh, fast, fast.
WTF?
Und tschüss.
Wo sind meine Leute?
Das ist doch nett.
Juhu, ein Shatter.
Ja.
Ähm.
Gut.
Übrigens, das durchgecharge war ziemlich bescheuert.
Mal angemerkt.
Irgendwie hat es mir aber so im kleinen Finger gejuckt gerade.
Ich hätte besser draufhauen sollen, als durchzuchargen,
weil wenn man durchchargt, dann machst du zwar ein bisschen Damage,
aber findest die Gegner meistens nicht.
Aber irgendwie hat es mir jetzt gerade so im Charge-Finger gejuckt.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ah, ich bin Gold-Damage.
Warte, ich bin gehackt, so.
Hackt, so.
Haha.
Oh, nee.
Ich habe so das Gefühl, mit Reinhardt fehlt mir ein wenig der Support vorne.
Hallo, EFDAL58.
Man kann es ja mal probieren.
Sag mal, Follow-Up, Leute.
Auf.
Wo ist denn hier was?
Jutsch.
Oh, nein, da hat er noch was gekillt.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Ja, ich lese gleich.
Ich lese gleich.
Moment, ich checke es nicht.
Ach, die löst sich gar nicht auf.
Die löst sich nicht auf.
Das ist einfach nur so ein, so ein, der hat halt mehr, mehr Movement Speed, das Viech.
Ich dachte, die macht sich unsichtbar.
Die macht sich gar nicht unsichtbar.
Die läuft einfach schneller.
Hast du schon keine Lust mehr auf Cod?
Nee, Cod auf dem PC ist ja schon nicht mehr spielbar.
Ist ja schon ein voller Cheater.
Leute, Leute!
Wo seid ihr?
Ey, da geht's nicht vorwärts gerade.
Top Reinhardt ist ja nicht so sinnvoll.
Hucken wir mal die ganzen Typen.
Oh, Mann.
Mann, der Shatter war auch lächerlich.
Aber trotzdem.
Da hätten wir jetzt viel besser reinkommen.
Ich meine, wir haben den Genji instant gepickt.
Oh, mein Gott.
Moment, Moment.
Irgendwas ist mit Drawtalk anders.
Moment, ich hab fünf Schuss.
What?
TF, ich hab fünf Schuss.
Oh, ich hab fünf.
Fünf.
Ich check's nicht.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Und ich mach keinen Damage.
Ich hab fünf Schuss und mach keinen Damage mehr.
What?
Was ist denn hier los?
Drawtalk verwirrt mich.
Was ist mit Drawtalk los?
Oh, man one-hitted nicht mehr.
Okay, das hab ich gelesen, dass man nicht mehr one-hitted.
Der neue Drawtalk verwirrt mich maximal gerade.
Ach, ich kann beim Laufen heilen.
Äh, okay, nee, nee.
Das check ich, das muss ich mir erst mal überlegen.
Das check ich nicht.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Drawtalk, der neue.
Der neue Drawtalk ist mir wirklich zu hoch.
Ja, stimmt, ja, stimmt, stimmt.
Ja, klar, klar.
Der macht weniger...
Stimmt, stimmt, ja, hab ich gelesen.
Der macht weniger Damage.
Was ist das hier?
So.
Ich warte jetzt einfach mal.
Oh, fast, fast, fast, fast.
What?
Ernsthaft?
Widow, warum killst du mich nicht?
Was ist denn das hier?
Warum kriegen wir das nicht?
Ist der Ton asynchron?
Nee, sollte eigentlich nicht.
Äh, das hab ich ja manchmal auf Twitch in letzter Zeit auch.
Ähm, refresh mal den Player.
Falls wirklich asynchron ist, muss ich was machen.
Aber ich glaube, das liegt...
Weil ich hab das auch öfters.
Jetzt aber.
Boah.
Bei dir, bei euch ist es asynchron?
Okay.
Ich probier's mal.
Ich mach's mal aus.
Äh.
Äh, Overwatch beenden, please.
Ja, ich weiß, dass Black screen ist.
Ich mach ja Overwatch aus.
Äh, was ist denn asynchron?
Mein Gelaber oder das Sound zum Game?
Das Sound zum Game, ne?
Also, der Sound vom Game hat nicht zu dem, was man in-Game gesehen hat, gepasst.
Game Sound, okay.
Ich denke mal, das sollte jetzt wieder passen.
Äh.
Ups.
Oh.
Äh.
Moment, Overwatch hat gerade einen Abgang gemacht.
Ich hab das Gefühl, es liegt an der Vorschau von OBS manchmal, dass die Spiele abkacken.
Kann man die OBS vorschauen?
Ah, Preview.
Preview disabled.
Gut, dann passiert jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts mehr.
Was, Taimo hat gestreamt gerade, Sandro?
Oh, ganz verpasst.
Passt das jetzt?
Warte mal, wir machen mal Training Range.
Und gucken, ob der Sound jetzt passt.
Der Stream immer noch, cool.
Vielleicht kann ich ja nachher noch mal...
...eine Runde gucken.
Stimmt.
Wobei, ich glaube, man sieht es mit einem anderen Held besser, ob Sound wieder passt.
Immer noch?
Ernsthaft.
Hä?
Äh.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, woran das liegt.
Äh, ich mach mal...
Wir testen mal kurz was.
Ich remove mal Game Capture.
Äh, Display Capture.
So, Achtung.
Ähm, guck mal, passt das jetzt, wenn ich hier unten klicke?
So, blum.
Wobei, das sieht man ja nicht, ne?
Man sieht das jetzt ja nicht.
Äh.
Okay, ich stell das wieder um.
Ähm.
Okay, starten wir Overwatch mal.
Ist zu spät?
Hä?
Ha.
Okay, ich starte jetzt erstmal wieder Overwatch.
Overwatch.
Ähm.
Gucken wir nochmal, ob es jetzt, ob es jetzt synchron ist.
Hä?
Was?
Ich hab noch nichts gemacht jetzt.
Was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, ich hab Overwatch schon rein, aus, wir haben ja sogar Desktop-Sharing gerade gemacht.
Ähm.
Kann man irgendwie...
Ich such jetzt mal hier.
Reset OBS Async.
Gibt's da was?
Remove, delete the sources.
Okay, das mach ich jetzt mal.
Ähm.
Wie, wie delete ich überhaupt Sources?
Audio-Sources, wie macht man das jetzt hier?
Properties.
Audio.
Ich mein, wenn das jetzt gar nichts hilft, ne?
Wenn das jetzt gar nicht hilft, dann mach ich halt Stream-Nummer außen wieder an.
Ich mein, man sieht's ja hier schon beim Klicken.
Passt, seid ihr euch sicher?
Only gets better with age.
Double kill.
Okay, wenn's nicht passt, mach ich das.
Ich mach jetzt den Stream an und wieder aus.
Okay.